- [laughs] I want to make
a toast to Chase
on his big VMA performance
no matter what Burger King
says.
- No.
- Where is Chase?
- Oh, uh, he's over there
talking to Michael Che.
The grind never stops.
- But Chase isn't the only one
I'm proud of.
To my CareBear, who's gonna be
in a big, fancy Hollywood movie
with Chase called
"Debra's Missing!"
- Nope. Uh, it's not called
"Debra's Missing."
It stars Debra Messing,
but thank you.
- And Brookey,
little Miss Manager!
To think that six months ago,
I would cry myself to sleep
so worried about you,
but look at you now!
- Aw, thanks, Mom.
Always great at toasts.
- Pat, why don't you tell them
your big career news.
- Oh, no, no, no, no, no.
It's nothing.
Tonight is about my kids.
Oh, wait, where's Lance?
I wanted to toast his shoes.
- Oh, um.
He couldn't make it.
- Aw, that's too bad.
- Is everything okay?
- What?
Oh.
Yeah, yeah.
I'm fine.
- Hi, can I get a card
for the table?
- Oh, you can just put
it under Billy Eichner.
- Of course.
- Actually, no.
I'm a proud, single
businesswoman.
You can put it
under Brooke Dubek.
- Of course.
- Actually, no.
- Guys, it's really busy
tonight.
- I love this family.
And I hope to always
be a part of it.
So take this
and put it on my card.
- Of course, Mr. Peters.
- Wait. Your name is...
Streeter Peters?
- Yes.
[both laughing]
- Hey, guys.
all: Chase.
- Hey, buddy.
What's going on?
- I'm glad you're all here
because I've been thinking
and I have a big announcement.
All this singing stuff
has been really cool,
but this fall
I'm gonna go
to college.
- What?
- College?
[dreadful choral music]
♪ ♪
[heart thumping rapidly]
- Streeter. [snaps]
[knife clatters]
- I am--oh, God.
I'm so sorry.
[laughing] I, uh--
I thought he said he was gonna
go to college.
- I did.
- [laughs]--Ah!
- I was talking to Michael Che
about what's next for my career
and he said maybe
I should go to college.
So I think I'm gonna go.
- Okay, so you're just...
not gonna be a singer anymore?
- I guess not
'cause I'd be in college.
- [groans]
- Well, I think
that's great, honey.
- Yeah, yeah.
So do I.
I think it's great.
But, um, you know--
Here's an idea.
How about we sleep on it?
And if you still want to go
tomorrow, we can apply then.
- I don't need to apply.
I already got into NYU.
- [clears throat] What?
- Oh, Cary,
like you, almost.
- Yeah, I tweeted at them,
and they said I could come.
- Oh.
Well, uh, what about all the
cool stuff you have coming up?
- Yeah.
- Streeter.
He got you a movie.
- I don't want to do a movie.
I wanna go to college.
- Yeah.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Yeah, no, no, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Yeah, yeah.
Yas, yas.
Yeah, yas, queen. Yeah.
- Yeah, it's great.
You know, it's so great.
I'm gonna go thank Michael
myself.
- [sighs]
[indistinct chatter]
- Excuse me, hi. Mr. Che?
- Hey.
- Did you just, um,
tell my brother, Chase, that
he should go to college?
- Yeah, I thought that'd
probably be the best thing
for him to do.
- Yeah, well,
as his sister,
I just wanted to say
I agree because I think
education is important.
- Well, that's great.
- But as his manager,
I just--I wanna say
you're a real piece of shit.
- Whoa.
Where did that come from?
Why?
- Why? Because I have finally
figured out
what it is that
I wanna do with my life
and what I'm good at
and you come along
and you [bleep] me.
I mean, not like that.
I mean, unless--
- No, definitely not.
- It's just, of course
I want him to go to college
if that's what he wants to do.
But--[chuckles sadly]
but what about me?
Like, what am I supposed to do?
- I mean, you can go
to college too.
- Jesus, what do you work
for college?
- All right.
- Listen.
Michael Che,
you seem like a good guy.
- I mean, I'm fine. I don't--
- But you took something
from me tonight.
And you took something
from my brother Cary.
So, I'm gonna take something
from you.
Yeah, I'm gonna...
I'm gonna take your drinks.
[bottles clinking]
I'm taking these.
They're mine now.
- Yeah.
- Thinking of killing yourself?
- What? No.
- If it wasn't for
the hot new lady in my life
[inhales deeply] I'd be dead
in the bathroom already.
- Ew. "Hot lady"?
- She doesn't want me
to tell anybody, yet.
[chuckles] But let's just say
she's a very special woman.
You don't know her.
- I'm sure I don't, Streeter.
- She's a beautiful woman,
and she raised
three beautiful children.
- Again, you don't know her.
- Okay, Streeter.
- I hope that someday
me and this beautiful woman,
who you do not know...
- [sighs]
- can take it to
the next level.
- Please don't talk
about you two having sex.
- I'm talking
about marriage, man.
- Oh, God.
- I'm talking about marriage.
- [sighs]
- We already had sex.
[dreadful choral music]
[heart thumping rapidly]
- You wanna get out of here?
- [bleep] yes.